[Music]
4:35 a.m. in DL Union those sirens are
the same as the ones that sounded 80
years ago announcing the bombing of the
town by Nazi aircraft an attack which
would start the Second World War no
words could ever make up for the
disaster that followed but today in the
early hours
Poland hosted its former attacker
Germany in the first of a series of
ceremonies of remembrance also aimed at
highlighting the friendship between the
two countries after the war it took
decades for the neighbor countries to
normalize the relations and
reconciliation is still an ongoing
process just aren't you biased for what
do you think it is easy to go to a town
that eight years before it was destroyed
in the bus trustee Alec fashion by the
people nation from previous generation
from the generation of their fathers and
grandfathers do you think it is easy to
stand here and look into the eyes of the
survivors to look into the eyes of the
children and grandchildren of those who
died commemorating World War two in a
country which lost six millions of its
people to the conflict will never be an
easy task and German President Frank
Martin Meyer cold or deniers he
underlined that Germany would face its
past there is not a single German who is
not moved when they reflect on this
trail of barbarism this also holds true
for those who reject these memories who
feel such a strong sense of shame that
they seek to escape into denial and
aggression song or poem Yui or at
Auschwitz
or other places with a short took place
without feeling shame an exercise in
contrition and a show of unity those
presidents also stressed a necessity of
finding new ways of remembrance at a
time when fewer and fewer eyewitnesses
remain to recount the horrors of the war
I'm joined now by a correspondent Simon
Young in Warsaw
Simon greetings to you what does this
anniversary mean for Poland after all
these years well I think this is
incredibly important anniversary for
Poland 80 years on since the start of
the war in Poland of course was the
first country that really faced the
onslaught from Nazi Germany Hitler's
plans to seize Layden's round room for
the German people as he described it in
the east of Europe and the waste wastage
that was laid to cities like Yellin but
also here in Warsaw another city that
was very largely destroyed with hundreds
of thousands of people here and as
you've said up to six million across
Poland who lost their lives the memory
of that has not gone away and it's
etched into the personal stories of many
Poles that's why they'll be focused on
not just this event here in Warsaw today
but I think commemorative events that
are being held across the country summon
how important is it for Germany to take
part in events like this well I think
it's extremely important for Germany to
be here it's something that's been
happening for a number of years now the
German president has been in Poland on
this occasion a number of times in the
past this year it's going to be in a
special focus because not only president
Sein Meyer will come
Berlin but also Chancellor Merkel as
well it's very unusual for the head of
state and the head of government to be
here together or to indeed to attend any
such function together so that's a
special sign I think of the respect and
the deep importance that Germany feels
and the message that they want to send
to poles on this occasion you know in
his speech the Polish president said
that frank-walter Steinmeier news
presence there was a form of a moral
compensation is that enough or should
Germany do more well there are demands
in Poland particularly from the Polish
government under the law and justice
party that's now in power to make
financial reparation and indeed there's
a parliamentary commission here in
Poland that's been looking into exactly
what kind of demand might eventually be
made it's due to report very soon and
that demand which Germany rejects saying
that these matters lie in the past
they've been dealt with in a formal
juridical sense financial sense
those shouldn't even if they haven't
been dealt with in a moral sense of
course in the past lives on those claims
do a cast something of a shadow perhaps
over these ceremonies it remains to be
seen whether that issue will be
mentioned in any direct way in any of
the speeches today that was DW Simon
Young Simon thanks so much